tonight we honor the man that gave us
everything we ever asked for and more
than we ever expected dustin
the thing i loved about pedroia a lot
like jeter his substance was his style
his style wasn't his substance even as
an opposing manager i couldn't take my
eyes off of him sometime he played with
such sincerity in his game and there
wasn't any look at me it was what can i
do to help the boston red sox win a game
tonight he will always be legendary in
boston i just want to thank most
importantly
the fans
all over the world because boston red
sox and red sox nation
is everywhere
hopefully i was a small part of doing it
the right way
and i just appreciate everybody and what
they've done for me
thank you guys
so much
martin perez 30 year old left-hander
from venezuela fenway park has not
become his favorite ballpark not at all
as a red sox the last two seasons six
and two
2.77 on the road at home two and seven
with an era upwards of six
his last two outings at fenway park he
lasted two innings against the astros
who lit him up for six runs dj le mayhew
digs in
swings on the first one bounces it down
to third debra's across the diamond one
quick out in ring of aaron judge you
would think the easy assumption is big
powerful right-handed hitter would love
fenway park anything but he's a 170
career hitter in this bar 2-0 pitch from
perez lofted to right down the line
and it will stay in play for hunter
renfrew here's gary sanchez last 23
games 410 with eight home runs and when
he connects it's usually a tape measure
shot but not this time perez who has had
his own difficulties at fenway works a
perfect first red sox coming up domingo
hermann comes in with a record of four
and four in 13 previous starts his era
is 4.17 through may 20th his record was
4-0 era under two since then in seven
starts oh and four era of nearly seven
michael chavis just back up from
worcester he's at the top of their
lineup lines this one to right and it
drops for a lead off hit here's alex
verdugo checks into 282 with nine home
runs davis takes off and the ball is hit
through the yankee infield davis is
going to stop at second base
back-to-back singles to open it in the
red sox first two on nobody out here's
jd martinez this one is whacked to
center field but right at aaron judge he
makes the catch and the runners hold
here's xander bogarts so now runners at
the corners with one out this ball's
lined to the left center field it will
get down one bounce off the monster and
the red sox are up two nothing and now
here's devers who in addition to his 18
homers has 23 doubles debra swings and
misses and down he goes so now here's
hunter renfro with boguards at second
and two out now the 2-0 pitch
is laced toward left center field and
that too will get down boguards crosses
the plate and it's three-nothing [ __ ]
hernandez at 231 the 1-2
got him two strikeouts in the inning the
bases are loaded so a walk a single a
soft single at that and an error the
bases are loaded with one out miguel and
duhar 271 with five home runs
got him looking third strikeout of the
game second in this inning and now he's
got a chance to wriggle out of it so now
it's up to the yankees knife hitter
clint frazier ball four and he does walk
in a run yankees have not hit perez hard
it's not going to get easier for perez
because now he's got to deal with dj le
mayhew how good has le mayhew been with
the bases loaded as a yankee hitting
over 500. fair ball down the right field
line
two run score and it's knotted up at
three the 01 pitch to judge is bounced
to third devers has it
flips to chavis and finally
the yankees are done in the second gary
sanchez starts it struck out his first
time
devers with a diving stop pops back up
and throws sanchez out there's three
parts of feeling the ball and executing
the play you got to catch it you got to
transfer it and you got to throw it you
handle all three of those flawlessly
stanton sent one whistling off the glove
of bogarts for a base hit and now voight
with an opposite field single two on one
out labor torres struck out his first
time
devers flips to second for one
and they turn the double play the 5-4-3
double play ends the yankee third a walk
a wild pitch
e1
first and third one out on the first
pitch renfro hits it hard to center
judge makes the catch martinez will tag
and he can cruise home and the red sox
take the lead again at four to three
only way or scheller turns this into a
double is if he's running hard as soon
as he makes contact considering how
cleanly verdugo played that and a base
hit through the hall on the right side
by andy berschel is steaming toward the
plate and the throw makes it close
they've got him by plenty clearly out
the yankees have run into more outs on
the bases than any team in the major
leagues two walks and two strikeouts in
the inning two on with two outs switch
hitter marwin gonzalez will be coming up
lofted into shallow center field
where judge is there to take it here's
your guy lizagas still on the mound i
just think he's a you know it's what
they look like i know a couple years ago
when i first saw him i said wow this
guy's got it he's just got it he's got
you know old scouts call he's got a good
face facing chavis as that one gets away
from sanchez
and so chavis has struck out but he
reaches first and the wiseaga finishes
off verdugo for the first out it's a
second strike out of the inning but only
the first out martinez strikes out and
ordinarily you would say that louisika
has struck out the side he's fanned all
three hitters he's faced but the first
one chavis reached when strike three got
away four strikeouts in the inning for
jonathan lewis again so they talk about
immaculate innings what's that called
excessive
something's wrong and he's not gonna
wait he's coming off and it's been a
struggle for him of late and this
appears to be another setback yeah this
is a leg issue grabs the hamstring the
left hamstring
and his knight is done and he knows it
renfro advances to second so it's an rbi
chance for christian vasquez it's softly
into center field and it's well placed
it drops for a hit and just what the red
sox were looking for they're up five to
three well now the yankees are looking
at matt barnes and based on history that
is not such a terrible prospect for the
yanks in 36 career appearances against
the yankees you know what matt barnes
era is no against new york
8.54
infield single sharp line drive single
two on the mayhew swings on the first
pitch could be a double play there's one
and there's two to end it the yankees
seem to have something going and just
like that it's all over